men are generally considered success
objects so
i mean did women ask questions that were
that were tied into things that women
seem most interested in like how tall is
he how successful is he what do you do
for a living i mean you're a
veterinarian so you're essentially a
doctor right i mean you've done well for
yourself did did they have any of those
like questions come up at you when you
guys were doing your pod stuff because i
didn't see that end up in the final
piece the only thing that really ended
up was like
you know you basically trying to size
them up for weight
um so those sort of questions were
completely
kosher you know i mean oh they could ask
what you did for a living how tall you
are
well no okay so not the tall as much
because that's physical but like as far
as like
you know your career and things like
that those were completely acceptable
to ask funny funny how that is eh you
know yeah you know it's okay for women
to find out you know what it is that you
do for a living which translates into
your earning potential right because
women are always concerned with a guy's
future you know sort of thing totally
but you can't
figure out what it is that she looks
like which is the most important thing
to men
yeah yeah i mean it is far more
important to men than it is to women i
mean it is important to both but
um i think we can we can agree upon upon
that and just so you know here's some
tea for you
so um this obviously never made the cut
but but i did get asked not how tall i
was but
i was asked by ayanna how tall
a couple of the guys were including
jarrett because
she was trying to narrow down the pool
for herself right so like this is ayanna
the same person who like
you know wanted to call me out
call me shallow called me a narcissist
everything between you know and it's
just really interesting it's like all
right
you you are so comfortable being the
person they portrayed you to be
um which is like this perfect you know
little angel um
and enough so that you can
try and like bring me down too and
that's not to say anything like terrible
about ayana she is a nice she is a nice
girl you know she's
there's nothing awful i have to say
about her
but
if you're gonna call me out for doing
something that you pretty much did
that's a little hypocritical
yeah are those two still together
yeah
um who else ended up together at the end
uh i can't remember the guy's name the
tall dorky guy he's very awkward with a
girl that used to be fat
oh yeah nick yeah oh i don't like that
guy at all
he's he's a he's an awkward strange
fella isn't he well aside from being
awkward and strange just
most of the time we were all very
suspicious of him because
he'd like roll up to the group and be
like
so
how's her sex lives it's like it's like
who asked you to ask us that like he was
probably a virgin before the show that's
probably why
maybe it was more like it was more like
he like
somebody like pulled him aside and they
were like all right nick we need you to
find out this information and like get
in there go so
we're like what are you are you even a
contestant are you secretly like were
you planted here you know like i never
trusted the guy like it's it was very
obvious like what the questions he would
ask
um that he would be trying to stir up
some kind of drama um
as far as the
you know that goes i wasn't affected as
much as like like shane and natalie and
stuff like that but right it was just
from watching it happen i'm like dude i
don't trust you at all
yeah
yeah he he definitely throw off some
weird vibes um shane also threw off some
really strange vibes too like the guy
looked like he was on something like i
don't know if he snorted a line every
day or if he's not like somewhere on the
spectrum with his personality like what
was up with shane
yeah um she's an interesting dude he had
like several
outbursts throughout the show like some
of which on camera many many many of
which off camera and i'm like this this
dude is unstable i i was still friends
with him like i you know um
he he was actually one of the guys that
i got along
got along with the most for whatever
reason um
we saw eye to eye on a lot of stuff but
a lot of times i was like this guy like
i'm a little worried about him
um i don't know if you've heard any of
the rumors that we're going around about
i don't know you kind of said some of
them
you know about like what's probably
going on and you're not completely wrong
about those you know without me saying
too much
um
yeah i mean i i hope i hope he's doing
okay like
what what upset me about shane the most
after filming
there was many times he showed up at my
condo
with nowhere to go needed a place to
crash like
sleeping on my couch like i'm helping
him out you know or like you call me in
the middle of the night like he needs to
talk something like that like
you know he
he's kind of a wreck and a lot of it is
because of the reasons that you kind of
alluded to
and he was just so
so quick at the reunion to like jump on
this thing with everybody else and like
once that happened you know it happened
kind of early on in the reunion
i was like okay like i know now that i
have no friends here and for that for
that reason i'm like i i'm like i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna start saying the
truth then you know like if this is how
it's gonna be i'm not gonna like
i'm not gonna play this game where like
everyone's protecting each other but
then coming after me i'm like all right
fine i'm just gonna start like
being honest about what happened hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha
you'll get 10 off on your first order
there's also the option to use the
subscribe and save model or regular
shipments will be sent over to you on a
regular basis and that gives you a
little bit of a discount and your
supplement facts are always broken down
over here thanks for watching i hope you
guys have an awesome day and again check
out that link it's pinned in the top
comment below in this video peace out
you